these us are you still paying money for
things you have to wait to do in real
life well no worries because I've got
more free stuff you could do online now
guys Dom lots of great suggestions from
V saucers today first from tipple Olive
Google search might be all floaty when
you can use Google gravity as soon as
your mouse touches it it collapses but
remains usable is it too slow for you
will try to kill yourself with caffeine
this site suggested by illustrator 777
lets you pick your favorite drink enter
your weight and find out how many energy
drinks you have to drink to die before
you do use the energy to multitask this
game comes from maddy
130 101 99 and over 9,000 accounts as
you play more and more things come up
that you have to do here I am using the
left and right arrows to balance ball up
and down to avoid triangles and shift to
jump too much stress too many buttons to
push
well Hall of games asks us why not just
hit here and head against a wall press
left then right over and over again the
more times you hit your head the more
freaked out and trippy the game becomes
too simple well Sid Vicious thinks big
world's biggest pac-man on this site you
can choose which board to play
everything's normal except when you
escape out the side you shift to the
next board once that game makes you sick
of pac-man do the opposite like a real
cool username anti pac-man here you play
as a ghost and try to get pac-man of
course when he turns you blue you've got
a rug now I've been a fan of this site
for a long time
Girl Talk makes great mashups and this
site visually lays out in real time
where every sample is
take a look or make your own music on
this site suggested by lots of V saucers
click a box and it will rhythmically
generate a tone draw whatever you want
for instance this is the sound of Vsauce
or gets symphonic with killer sax
recommendation you have to manipulate
arrows to direct energy into boxes to
hear new instruments or be darker with
webby nominee and a somnium
this site uses your webcam to detect
brightness and you actually have to turn
out the lights or find a dark place in
order for her to dream now every dream
she has is unique and completely crazy
but as soon as you turn the lights back
on or even check your phone
she'll know and wake up and end the
dream even more crazy is psycho paint
this site is also up for a webby and it
lets you mimic the brushstrokes of great
painters on your own pictures here's
Laura and I let me just jazz it up but a
little over here and there beautiful I
leave you with something new Vsauce
Leanback it's a playlist I hope to make
every week that contains videos from
other creators that I think are really
cool the playlist lasts as long as an
actual television episode so it's like
Vsauce but grown up so if you ever want
to lean back and relax and let the
videos change themselves and have Vsauce
be your tour guide check it out there's
a link in the description and let me
know what you think because I'm very
interested to know and hey as always
thanks for watching
you
[Music]